Hey traders, it's Mike Carr, and in
today's video, I'm going to follow up on
yesterday's video where I talked about
my order flow entry model
which was exhaustion following
absorption. And you know, today there
really wasn't much signs of exhaustion,
pure exhaustion in the order flow. But
there was still a couple opportunities
to be had today. There was this one
right after the cash open, and then
shortly thereafter, about 45 minutes
later, there was another exhaustion
print coming up in here at a high.
But we'll talk about both of these. So
this morning,
right, cash open, we started selling
down. And we got to this point here
where there was an exhaustion print.
Now, what was interesting here is, you
know, cash opened here at 8:30 Chicago
time, then we get this big push down. We
have very strong negative delta 1429,
which, you know, since the cash open,
obviously is is your highest negative
delta. And to be honest, you know,
anything, you know, on a 1-minute chart
in the E-minis is pretty strong. I was
looking for some potential more
follow-through. Now, the problem was we
were at the low of the day, okay? And we
had this blue area here which came in
from earlier, all right? It it came in
from this low that we had right after
7:30, right? We did make this low
right after 7:30. We did have an
exhaustion print, but again, you know,
that's an exhaustion print that's coming
in right after the number.
And again, I mean, we do have the
exhaustion print of four right here. But
again, you know, it's it's right after
the CPI.
So you're you're going to have thin
volumes anyway. So cash opened, and we
have this nice
big push down, right? I mean, we we
dropped from 7415
all the way down almost to our lows.
We just got down to towards 7400, and
then we post that exhaustion print. Now,
what was interesting, there was a few
things. So, we got the big negative
delta here, right? -1429.
Again, you're going to be looking for
some follow-through. And what happens is
we go inside on this bar. We do have
um you know, it's a doji candle. Opens
and closes at the same uh price. Now,
what always makes me nervous of, you
know, continuation is
we got that
push down here at 8:36, but we go
inside. That's not a good sign. But then
this green bar here, it ended up green,
but for a while it was a red bar and it
had strong negative delta. You see -362.
It's quite strong. It ended up at -173.
So, you know, when you sort of pick
apart what's happened in the bar, well,
it ran into some liquidity right here,
right? Which is a sign of absorption,
right? There was strong selling in
there. We'd get past it for the most
part, and then we just print five. Now,
you know, you got 423, 398, 161, 103.
So, there is strong selling here, here,
here, here. And we get past it. And but
then we only trade five. So, you know,
it's telling me in that sort of
tug-of-war between aggressive sellers
and passive buyers
what took place is the aggressive
sellers just sort of, you know, ran out
of of ammunition, so to speak, right?
They didn't have any more left to sell.
We do have a nice volume decline here.
5, 103, 161,
398, 423. So, even though there was
strong selling into this low, it was
stronger here, but progressively weaker,
progressively weaker, progressively
weaker, capped off with just the five.
So, we got that exhaustion print. That's
what this
green line going across means. And we
get a nice rally, right? Initially, the
next bar goes inside, but we did break
out the high of this bar uh two bars
later. And, you know, we we make a nice
move from about 05 all the way up. They
didn't quite get to 15, which is what I
would have liked to got to the 14. And
then, you know, the selling came back in
and then we dropped it back down. So,
there was there was some
meat to be had on this move up. Again, I
would have liked to see it go 10 points
to up here, but then it just it just
sort of petered out in here, which is
you know, which is trading, right?
Sometimes it doesn't exactly go to your
profit target.
Now,
a little bit later, whoops, a little bit
later, there was uh
another rally off our lows. We made new
lows, okay? So, we get down here, we
make this new low, 73.91 and 1/2. Again,
no exhaustion prints, right? You can
just see there's very few exhaustion
prints today.
Which tells me that, you know, trading
is sort of normal in the sense that, you
know, since you don't have as many
exhaustion prints, um you know, the
market is just doing what it's supposed
to be doing. It's facilitating the
trade. Now, we did rally
from this low. We get up here and we
have this nice exhaustion print up here
at this swing high.
Right? Seven.
And as we're going up, you see the
deltas,
right? It's positive, 730, force
positive 463, positive 48. Then it's
negative, minus 52. So, even though the
market is going up, the aggressive
buying is weakening.
All right? It if you're expecting this
market to continue to go up, it's going
to keep putting in
consistently strong positive deltas.
You know, um to be honest, the 730, the
463 is strong, but the just 48, that's
nothing. And then it turns 52. Then you
get another bar here, this little doji
bar, it's at 42. Okay? So,
whatever strength we had there in terms
of aggressive buying has weakened.
Now, it's unfortunate that
you know, to me this is a very bearish
bar. We've got a lot going in here in
addition to the exhaustion print, right?
We've got, you know, a thin print in
here, zero, a two, we got three sauna
balances, we got an engulfing value
area, we got a bearish prominent point
of control. Next bar starts to go down,
it goes down about five ticks. Next bar
goes down about two ticks then reverses,
pops up just above our high
to stop you out, and then it makes that
move down into new lows.
Now,
it's unfortunate, right? I mean, but
this is a trade that I would take 10
times out of 10 times, right? A bar like
this is is something to me that that's
very bearish. It's just just There was
just sort of this residual leftover
buying that had to be facilitated, had
to be executed before the market dropped
off.
Um you know, some traders will use a
second chance entry, meaning they get
stopped out right away,
um but nothing's really changed in the
order flow, even though you had positive
delta 453, positive delta of 279
is lesser than the 453. Okay, so if
you're just waiting for this bar to come
in, and it's got minus 76 delta, you
know, you just have a a second chance
entry to get short at where you just
were short. Hopefully you could have
caught that move. So,
you know, this was a nice 10-point move.
So again, you know, today in the S&P's
there there just wasn't that many
opportunities in terms of exhaustion
prints
um in in the in the morning, right? I
don't see any other exhaustion prints
coming in at swing highs or swing lows
today. There's just not much, right?
There's none, right? There's just those
two opportunities.
You know, sometimes the market presents
a lot more opportunities, sometimes it
doesn't. Now,
you know, when when one market is kind
of quiet as S&P's were, even though
we're selling off, but you know, in
terms of quietness, in terms of what I'm
looking for, I'll also look at other
markets. Now, ultra bonds, right? Is is
a nice market to
look at in addition to S&P's. You know,
it has nice movements as well. And up
here, and I don't have the exhaustion
prints turned on, but
we have our
you know, it's kind of a mostly quiet
session. Obviously, we had CPI come out
today. Maybe the market was waiting for
that. But
about 15 minutes after
the number came out, we got exhaustion
print here 10.
Okay?
Now, again, you know, from about 3:00 in
the morning or you know, actually since
midnight, which is right over here.
We'll call this midnight. You know,
we're trading in this range here
to here.
And we get this 10 contracts in here,
right? Which is my exhaustion print.
Now,
you know, people say, "What What do you
use as a number for exhaustion prints,
nine or 10?" You know, in the old days,
I used to like single digits, but you
know, 10 to me is is close enough,
especially in a market like interest
rates, where you can trade a lot of
volume.
Um 10 is fine. And it's coming in just
as you sort of poke out above this area
that you were trading, you know, in this
range. And more importantly,
it's coming in at a potential turning
point, right? This is a swing high.
And we got this nice move lower from
there. Um obviously, this bar has a
bearish prominent point of control as
well. It's got a bearish value area
that's not traded into in the next bar.
So, it's this bar has actually got a lot
of things nice things going for it. So,
you know, even though you didn't have
anything in the S&P's,
um you know,
other markets will give you trading
opportunities. All right? So, you just
got to be able to pivot into another
market when your primary market, in this
case, um E-minis, you know,
wasn't necessarily giving you very much
to go off of in terms of exhaustion
prints.
So,
hope you enjoyed this video, and I'll
see you guys on the next video.